Well, if you remember, we stopped execution with the JavaScript debugger,
in the original HTML source file.
Looking back at the code, here, the debugger in line 19 paused execution.
In the web console, we created and appended an new SVG, which we then
drew a chart in, all before continuing from the initial debugger statement.
So when we stepped past the debugger statement at line 19, the original code got
run, which appended another svg to our page and added a second chart to it.
Usually, this isn't too much of an issue, because in practice you don't develop
your final chart in this interactive way where you pause execution,
write some code in your interactive console and then continue execution.
Usually, a visitor comes to your graphic, the HTML gets loaded,
and the JavaScript code gets run once.